Film Courage: Something you said in the last question reminds me of the Missed Opportunities
scenario, when I was a little girl there was
a section in our town newspaper where I grew
up about “Missed Opportunities.”
I’ll never forget this one post was about
a man who saw some woman and he described
her in great detail and said “We shared
a moment” and if this is you, can you please
call me?”
And I’ve never forgotten that post.
This was pre-Craigslist, and I know all those
posts exist now online.
But why are we so inthralled with this idea
of missed opportunity?
Pamela Jaye Smith: A missed opportunity is
a factor of idealism because that opportunity
is not fact.
It’s an opportunity.
It’s a possibility.
An onto that we can cast all of our dreams.
And I think most of us have all had those
moments, you glance across a room, you’re
crossing a street you look at them and they
look at you and you go “Yeah….???!!”
And then you both walk on.
And you think “Should just go stand on that
street corner and wait for them to come by
again?”
And so people do.
But I think the thing about a missed opportunity
most at its core, it offers that question
“What If?”
Might that have been perfection that deep
in our hearts we are all striving for?
Film Courage: So do most romantic comedies
feature the missed opportunity or even if
it’s just a friend at a wedding that they
see across the table that they say hello to.
Isn’t that sort of the core?
Because of the “What If?”
Pamela Jaye Smith: Yes…the Missed Opportunity
can be the entire storyline of an entire film
or the main story or the main storyline of
it.
For instance in FOUR WEDDINGS AND A FUNERAL,
the Hugh Grant character definitely has a
missed opportunity through line.
And fortunately he resolves it and he and
Andie McDowell get together…again.
But within the 3-part structure of the romantic
comedy, that’s the sad part about and the
tense part about that second section.
Yeah!
You saw what it could be and now it’s gone.
Because one of you had to move or somebody
got in the way or someone else’s impositions
of propriety are keeping you apart.
And so that missed opportunity is a vessel
(if you will) for idealism and perfection
really bothers us and we are driven to pursue
what might be a perfect situation.
And now…it’s a romantic comedy and they
always stop when the people get together,
right?
We don’t have to get into the part about
disillusion and domesticity and all that stuff.
But we get to keep that illusion of perfection
and idealism.